hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everybody that asks questions on my Game
of Thrones videos this weekend there's
been so much news lately they actually
they just cast max von sydow as the
three-eyed Raven now I think they recast
the role probably just because they're
going to be doing a lot more scenes with
them and they just want an actor that
they feel is up to the task I guess
that's a bummer if you are a big fan of
the last actor to play the role bit
early he was only on screen very very
briefly at the end of season 4 so I mean
it's not like the mountain where they
were in like big extended scenes and
then they were recast they've recast the
mountain three times the guy that's the
mountain right now the big guy that
started in season 4 he's the third
person to play that role it's just
further confirmation that there's going
to be a lot more brand stuff going on in
season six there's still a few people
that they haven't cashed yet so just
expect more news like that to start
rolling out in the next month or so do
not be surprised though if they just
opted to not do a casting video this
season that they could totally do that
they might try and keep as many secrets
as possible hopefully HBO will confirm
some stuff but you know if we don't get
that casting video that I'm not
expecting a whole lot on a question so
here we go overkill asks do you think
the show would introduce glass candles
in maester Marwan and Sam wells
storyline like if Samwell goes to the
Citadel I you know glass candles they
would probably just have as a prop in
that they just they wouldn't call them
out you just noticed them in the
foreground as far as maester Marwan I'm
not expecting him just because his plot
line in the books is already like
dramatically diverged from what they've
done on the show without explaining
which book storyline he's associated
with I'll just say that several
characters that are associated with that
specific storyline have already been
changed so yes we will get arch maesters
but they might not be like really
notable ones from the books it might
just be an offhanded thing it depends on
how many scenes we get with Sam well I'm
not expecting a whole lot at least not
outside of his family because it looks
like they're casting his family so most
of the substantive Samwell stuff will
probably happen with those characters
the only thing I'm really expecting from
the Citadel and in terms of scenes in
exposition and plot is him just pouring
through documents I don't think it's
going to be like Hogwarts or anything
where they do like extended class scenes
just remember though that there are two
more seasons after season six so even if
we don't see a whole lot of the Citadel
we could see more in future seasons
next question kdj asks where do you
think the show runners will go with
randyll Tarly plotline I would say you
know mostly tied up with what Samwell is
doing and with what's going on in King's
Landing samwell's concerns are up at the
wall and Randall Charlie's are not
currently but he's probably going to try
and tell his father about what's been
going on based on the way he said that
he is perceived by his father like his
father thinks he's a total fool and he
doesn't want to become a maester so I'm
not expecting randyll Tarly to listen to
sam ball a lot just remember Sam wells
family is from the reach so they are
bannermen to the Tyrells so if any
conflict erupted then randyll Tarly
legendary battle commander would
probably fight with the Tyrells against
the Lannisters or the brass Ian's
depending on how you think about it next
question Miffy asks since Hannibal is
cancelled and Mads doesn't have any
projects that you know about do you
think the producers would get him to be
you're on oh I'm sure like there are so
many actors that they talk about when
they they're picking like the big
characters from the books but there have
been no comments officially about Mads
Mikkelsen joining the cast I do get a
lot of like Mads Mikkelsen questions
whenever I do you're on stuff and videos
and I use his picture that's just
because he looks the part that that's
not because he's been cast or anything
it's just for fun so like if I use his
picture is not because he's been cast
it's just that there are certain
characters in the books that like when
you talk about them and you look for
pictures there's nothing there's not a
lot of media for really obscure book
stuff so you kinda have to get a little
janky with it like when I use like Lily
Collins pictures for Liana stark look
there's just there's not a lot of Liana
stark art work out there Mads Mikkelsen
is great though it be wonderful to have
them on the show but I'm not a huge fan
of them casting big actors just because
they're big actors I'd rather than pick
someone obscure if it's going to be more
appropriate so be careful what you wish
for when you want like really big actors
to come on TV shows so sometimes they
just they tend to overpower the
narrative with their celebrity next
question Roger asked with all these HBO
changes being announced when do you
think we'll get more on a prequel I
would say you know most of the prequel
talk will probably start picking up
around season eight like as we head into
production of season eight or even even
during season seven so it's going to be
a while typically big networks don't
announce stuff like that until
tracks or signs so it's one thing to say
we would love to see a prequel it's
completely different for them to say yes
we are doing a prequel because because
that would imply that they've actually
signed people to develop it they got
actors that they're testing for certain
roles in the last year or so george r
martin has said that dunk and egg is
being discussed if you haven't read that
yet you'll actually you'll get another
chance this fall the books are at a
print but this fall they're combining
the three Duncan egg books into a
compendium called night of the Seven
Kingdoms it doesn't come back till
October but when it does drop I'll give
away a bunch of copies next question
Joseph S do you think that brand will
ever physically leave the cave in season
six no I don't think that he's ever
going to walk outside that cave again I
think he's stuck there for the rest of
his life however many hundreds of years
he ends up surviving the three-eyed
Raven when he meets them for the first
time says you'll never walk again but
you will fly that just means he's going
to be working into birds but the Raven
also says that darkness will be his
friend and it's kind of a metaphor but
also a literal thing it's dark
underneath the tree but darkness also
implies something a little bit more
sinister so hopefully they'll explore
that in season 6 I don't know how many
brand scenes will get but if they're
casting a really badass actor then he's
probably to be on screen for a while
next question a ditch as if they do a
flashback to the Tower of joy will they
recast Sean Bean are cast someone
younger that looks like him to play Ned
no I think the day with his character
specifically they would probably just
try and age him down with a combination
like practical makeup and CG the reason
they didn't do that was Cersei is
because there was like a 30 year gap
that they were trying to close the Circe
in the flashback is closer to 10 years
old and Ned Stark at the Tower of joy is
only about 16 years ago so the leap
isn't quite so dramatic next question
Jake asks do you think that Randall
Charlie will approve of Sam well if he
sees him in season six and hears about
him killing the white Walker and saving
Gilly so you're saying like yeah what
will he be happy you know think that Sam
turned into a success no absolutely not
I think he's gonna hate Sam no matter
what what may ma'am even I hate him but
he'll be mean to him no matter what it
sounds too amazing from a story
standpoint that his father would
disapprove of him no matter what he did
like Sam well saves the realm you know
like season eight Samwell saves the
realm in the war for the dawn randyll
Tarly still doesn't like him that much
some people are just [ __ ] and no
matter what you do you will never please
them and I think that's what Sam wells
relationship with his father is going to
be it's a lot like Tywin's relationship
with his children even if Jamie did
everything that Tywin wanted he wouldn't
jump across the table to give him a hug
or anything plus you know do you kind of
feel like that Sam wells lot in life you
know that no matter how good he is like
Gilly is the only person that's ever
going to show him any kindness outside
of Jon Snow and who knows when Sam wells
gonna see jon snow again next question
le asks how did Jack and jugar end up in
the Kingsguard in season two when aria
saved him well I mean he was probably
there because he wanted to be there
someone that skilled just doesn't like
sit around like he could totally pick a
lock if he wanted to he might have been
in King's Landing on other business but
I think he saw Aria and just saw an
opportunity there's this big
conversation that goes on with fantasy
stories about the idea of Destiny and
predetermined events there are gods and
a song of ice and fire so how much are
they trying to influence the lives of
individual people I feel like that's not
what game of thrones is about the reason
that I think so many people like it is
because it kind of flaunts that trope in
that characters they might have some
sort of implied destiny but they still
totally have free will so people are
free to make terrible terrible decisions
Jaime Lannister is probably the best
example of that if there was some sort
of grander plan that jackin was on like
if he was specifically targeting Arya
Stark if there was no other reason for
him to be in King's Landing then I think
we'll learn about it during season 6 but
just remember during season 5 Jack and
Hegar said that it's all the same to the
many-faced God implying that the
many-faced God doesn't micromanage the
lives of individual people next question
Leon asks do you think if John is
declared dead by the Nights Watch and he
gets resurrected he'll no longer be a
member of the Nights Watch as his oath
states it shall not end until my death
so you're asking like yeah would he
leave the Nights Watch I know a lot of
people have been asking this question
I'm not sure why because I feel like
even if he was freed from his oath to
the Nights Watch he would still have to
deal with the army of White Walkers in
the wall would be the place where that
battle is gonna go down so it's not like
he's just gonna like right off into the
sunset or anything like that if you do
want to get really technical yes he
would be freed from his oath
to the Nights Watch but that would
assume that Alliser Thorne unlike the
other authorities at the Nights Watch
recognized that he died and then was
reborn so there's like a couple hoops to
jump through that they might just
sidestep the only way I see him leaving
the wall is if he gets co-opted by the
White Walkers I mean because just
because he's getting resurrected does it
mean he's automatically going to be good
there are multiple ways that he could be
resurrected and usually when people do
get resurrected by the red God you know
I'm the better side of things their
personalities change dramatically so the
jon snow that we get back won't be the
one that died next question alee asks
why is he gonna go through with the
trial I assume just as soon as they let
her go she was going to destroy the high
Sparrow and his followers well the
problem with that is is that she is part
of the few they are part of the many
that was the high Sparrow response to
the queen of thorns when she threatened
to cut their grain off the high Sparrow
was just saying that the peasantry
outnumbers the nobles many many times
over and he has the popular vote right
now the entirety of King's Landing hates
the crap out of Cersei that that's what
that whole walk of shame was about
everyone was like you're terrible your
trash I'm gonna throw trash at you we
hate you so even if Cersei were to try
and use the City Guard or the Kingsguard
to try it and put down the high Sparrow
they still have like 10 times a hundred
times more people that they could
marshal so even though Cersei isn't
stuck in a black cell like Tyrion was
during season four she's still going to
be forced to sit trial thank you so much
everyone for submitting questions not as
many ian mcshane questions that there
was going to be but congratulations to
this week's giveaway winners so shield
beats and Beth flew terza you guys both
went amazon gift cards is just a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card message
me on the back end of my channel so i
can get your contact info what i'm going
to do for my next bonus video is just a
character video based on some of the
people that I've been talking about I
haven't made a separate season six
playlist yet so like all of the season
six videos I've been doing in the bonus
videos or in the season five playlist
for Game of Thrones so if you want to
see like all the stuff that I've done
like you haven't browsed the playlist
yet i'll put a link in the description
but usually anytime i do a game of
Thrones video it goes in like the season
five playlist right now it's currently
it's like my master playlist for
everything and related WTF news if you
guys haven't seen I did a dead
pull video this morning there's going to
be a trailer a red band trailer tomorrow
it's going to be so much fun so you can
click here to check out that Deadpool
video learn what's going on with that if
you don't know and you can click here to
learn all about Game of Thrones eighth
season plan in the prequel thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow so get
ready to blow out your collective
sphincters cuz my trailer is coming